we're just about set for braves baseball
as we open up a three-game series with
the phillies here on the banks of the
mighty chattahoochee max freed who gets
the start for the braves nine base on
balls to 28k
something to look for tonight that
slider his slider was so good last start
let's see if he goes back to it we cut
you to 243 a homer 12 rbis
and the payoff is a swing and a miss
mccutcheon chased one up and out of the
zone
and max freight has his first strikeout
upper part of the zone got mccutchen to
chase it here's segura
fly ball out to short right field that's
going to drop in for a hit
and jt will cruise to third
two bloops
and the phillies have runners on the
corners for phil gosselin here is phil
goslin
rounder to third charging
is riley throws a one hopper off the bag
a run will score they throw back to
second in time to get segora all right
but the phillies do score a run here's
the tag on segora before he gets the bag
first run allowed by freed before the
fourth inning this year aaron nola lola
two and one at 2.05 era travis darno
swing it a miss got him with a curve
ball
two outs here in the bottom of the first
that's a big out because he's been
tearing it up against right-handed
hitters
here's marcelo zuna d.h again
pitch
ozuna shoots it to right field at bay's
hit freddy on his way to second woman
quinn got to it cleanly
and a good approach good result for
ozuna and here is johann camargo
in the air to right center field roman
quinn speeding back so is kangri he
jumps and makes the catch what a play by
scott kingry he went up onto the fence
and pulled it in
one out here in the second inning
what a heck of a play
one on one out and ender in crte the
batter
swing and a miss since ciarte strikes
out second strikeout for nola and so
christian pache will live a boyhood
dream right now in atlanta he'll step to
the batter's box as a big leaguer for
the first time 3-2 pitch is on the way
there goes riley it is strike 3 a
fastball and arinola as his third
strikeout he works around a leadoff walk
and the phillies maintain a one-nothing
lead and he'll start at the third with
the villain scott kingery who has made
the play of the night already
there's that slider man good pitch
two outs excuse me two strikeouts for
max freed one away mccunchon leads at
first twitched didn't go and hoskins
chased that a swing and a miss
third strikeout for max free second to
sinning great pitch instead of going to
that curveball you went off speed
something to throw him off the fastball
chip but it's that slider 86 down in the
zone freddie freeman at first darnow the
hitter he struck out his first time up
it's a lot that smoke towards center
kingery on his horse still going back
that ball is into chattahoochee falls
darn
second home run against the phillies
this year it turns the game into the
braves favor and here's ozuna
another scorcher hit towards center
kingery still going back he's to the
track it's another splashdown
back-to-back homers for atlanta
that one i think hit off the back wall
before it found the waters
well he's trying to go away it ran kind
of back out of the middle of the
plate you know how good marcel is in
fastballs and johan camargo the batter
he was robbed by kingery his last time
line drive right center field that's
down that's headed for the braves
bullpen riley around third he's going to
score camargo doubles off the right
center field wall
it's a 4-1 game so the baseball gods do
smile on camargo a line drive to right
center field a thing of beauty two
strikes for gregorius
and that's tipped and caught by darneau
max freed has his fourth strikeout gets
a tough man to whiff gregorius tells you
how good his stuff is one on one out for
roman quinn who bounced out to dansby
his first time up and a swing and a miss
max free takes care of roman quinn
camargo hits two on nobody out braves up
4-1
sharply hit and that is a fair ball
headed for the right field corner duval
scores riley on his way to third he's
going to be stopped and camargo has a
two double knight ncrt the batter o2
pitch
line toward left field that ball is
going to be caught great diving grab by
mccutcheon but another run will score as
riley comes home on a sacrifice fly and
back to the top of dansbury swanson and
stansbee awaits the 3-1 and hammers that
toward bull nice play that time tough
play bad throw it gets away from hoskins
at first another run will score and
dansby's on his way to second balm has
had a forgettable defensive frame here
two errors and maybe a throwing error on
that play it's 7-1 atlanta
and here's darnold there they go the
pitch
is lined into center field kingery's
coming on diving try can't get it ball
dropped safely freddie never stopped
running now he slams on the brakes as
darneau has another rbi hit three rbi
night for the braves catcher that makes
it eight to one well now ozuna and
another 3-2 pitch swing in a high fly
ball wall up deep left field ozuna has a
two homer night good hitters take
advantage of marcel second homer of the
night his eyes got big on that pitch and
here's pache again yeah this is a good
matchup
little roller right side that's going to
find the outfield grass and there's the
first big league hit look at him
celebrate first major league hit
comes in the sixth inning in atlanta and
that ball is headed for the trophy case
to bring up andrew knapp
look at the nap time snap out toward
left field it's over the head of pachay
and it'll be an rbi double for andrew
knapp who just keeps on hitting it's
sandra mccutchen who's over three with a
walk
fly ball well hit right center field
ender full head of steam up against the
wall he's got it and what a way to end
it
long running catch for ender in ciarte
and the braves are back home after a
couple of days off with an 11-2 win